hey this is another one of the sort of I
mean like I would I guess I would use
the word unintended consequences
but maybe it's predictable consequences
doctors
who are now being presented with
pregnant women with cancer
are increasingly skittish about treating
the women for fear that they could end
up arrested as a result of anti-abortion
laws and we have to think this through
this is kind of like the the logic of it
and if you're interested in this there's
a good article in Business Insider a
pregnant cancer patients may die because
doctors fear treating them could now
count as illegal abortion experts say so
here's the gist of it pregnant woman has
cancer
um you treat her for cancer as a cancer
doctor it doesn't go well and she dies
or the stress of the treatment and the
cancer while under your care causes a
miscarriage there are states
criminalizing miscarriage and with Roe v
Wade overturned those laws are now
active in many states this goes beyond
just pregnant cancer patients any
patient coming to coming into the
emergency room and Pregnant doctors may
be saying do I need a lawyer here do I
need a politician here to figure out
what if the treatment they need could
cause a miscarriage
oh but David there's exceptions to all
this stuff if you look at the laws in
most of these states the exceptions are
potentially meaningless unless I mean
listen we don't every state has
different laws but you are increasingly
having a situation here
where professional medical professionals
who know what the right course of
treatment is based on medicine are now
being second guessed by politicians with
an agenda tied into the criminal justice
system and if it means jail time if a
politician gets their way if x y or Z
happens as a result director indirect of
the treatment you provide to a pregnant
woman be it cancer or any other kind of
emergent situation in an emergency room
are doctors really going to be providing
the best care in those situations it
seems that the answer is no so I will
link to this article I would I would
encourage you to check it out and
um you you could end up in a situation
where doctors say I'm not comfortable
administering chemo which you need
uh because you're pregnant and it could
end up with me in legal hot water now I
I am sure that the right would say that
is not the intent of these laws but as
we have learned many times the intent
and the consequences
are two different things and in many
cases could be completely divorced from
each other so predictable
horrifying the United States of America
in some states in a post-rovey world era
in 2022.